Wolverine is back and he's never looked
more like himself but this classic suit
raises a lot of questions about what's
going on with the X-Men and the MCU
what is this place ever since production
began on Deadpool 3 rumors surrounding
the upcoming three-quote have been going
ballistic online reports have suggested
a slew of nostalgic cameos are on the
way including three of the original
X-Men joining Hugh Jackman's Wolverine
pair that with the recent news of
Jennifer Garner's return as Elektra and
Deadpool 3 is shaping up to be quite the
multiversal story as the Merc with a
mouth makes his big debut in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe as if that wasn't
exciting enough Ryan Reynolds and Hugh
Jackman woke up this morning and decided
to break the internet giving fans the
first official look at Deadpool and
Wolverine in Deadpool 3. while both
heroes are back and looking better than
ever all eyes are on Jackman as he
finally gets the opportunity to Don
Wolverine's iconic yellow suit on the
big screen and it's just as glorious as
anyone could have imagined Wolverine's
new look for Deadpool 3 looks as if he's
jumped straight from the pages of
Marvel's astonishing X-Men run which
Ackman sporting the classic yellow suit
with blue accents that look just as
vibrant as they ever did in the comics
interestingly this version features
sleeves covering Jackman's arms
something in his comic book counterpart
never grew accustomed to the first look
also notably doesn't include Wolverine's
iconic cowl but given how comic Acura
Jackman's costume is it probably isn't
far behind him while Wolverine's iconic
yellow suits is more than enough to
build hype for Deadpool 3. it could also
give fans an idea of what Marvel Studios
plans to do with the X-Men in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe while Jack Vince
Wolverine may be making his MCU debut in
a blue and gold suit that doesn't mean
he's going to be the mcu's Wolverine
reports suggest that Deadpool 3 and
other movies in the Multiverse Saga
might be more of a swan song for the fox
X-Men characters and if that's the case
we'll probably be getting a bit of a
reset down the line with the mcu's
version of the character that would
likely mean a whole new actor and a
whole new outfit with the eventual MCU
Wolverine may be taking on the classic
golden brown suit instead first
introduced an Uncanny X-Men number 139
Wolverine's golden brown suit quickly
became an iconic design for the
character wearing it throughout the 80s
and early 90s in recent years the
costume has had a Resurgence with Logan
wearing a modernized version for the
current X-Men run priming it for a live
action debut as for the X-Men
Wolverine's yellow suit in Deadpool 3
bodes well for the entire team X-Men
movies of the past decided to forego
many of the characters comic book
costumes Wolverine's New Look suggests
that Marvel Studios will likely stick a
little closer to the source material for
the X-Men's suits this time around now
that comic book movies are much more
mainstream than they were 20 years ago
it's only natural to showcase the
vibrant unique costumes that originally
made the X-Men Staples in the comics
industry of course this is all
speculation but it certainly seems like
X-Men fans are in for a treat whenever
the mutants come to the MCU in full
force while Deadpool and Wolverine look
better than ever for their upcoming
multiversal buddy cop Adventure Hugh
Jackman finally getting his hands on
Wolverine's yellow suit pays off his
long-standing commitment to bring Logan
alive over 20 years ago when X-Men first
hit theaters it infamously threw out the
character's vibrant colors choosing to
style everyone in a uniform black
leather look instead what would you
prefer yellow spandex
well the scene is now iconic the simple
answer was yes and vans have been
waiting to see their favorite X-Men
characters on their Classic Suits ever
since in Wolverine's case that day never
came until Deadpool 3 hits theaters but
that didn't stop the studio from teasing
Jackman in the yellow suit The Wolverine
filmed an alternate ending featuring
Yukio gifting Logan a yellow and brown
suit but the scene ended up not making
the Final Cut in an interview with
Screen Rant director James Mangold said
I somehow feel that if somehow we ever
put Hugh Jackman into one of those
outfits people would not be happy while
that may have been the case back then
fans seemed more than excited to see
Jackman finally get his yellow suit in
Deadpool 3.
foreign